wherever you go surfing even if there's
no waves it's still a good time good
times bad battle wounds Matthew
McConaughey showing off his son's seared
scars or as he calls them surf souvenirs
you catch one way and you get down the
face of it
and you fall off about 40 seconds later
then you're back at it yeah the Oscar
winner is a big champion of the sport so
it's no surprise he takes to Instagram
with a proud dad moment putting his son
Levi's bandaged back on full display in
a rare look at his little ones you can
be out there for five more hours and not
get away but if you get one you're up
for the rest of the week Matthew and his
wife Camila Alves welcomed their
firstborn in 2008. Levi Alves
McConaughey and just a few weeks later
he was telling E.T they were already
preparing Levi to hit the waves we
already start in the water we haven't
got him in the beach yet but um so far
there's nothing
natural like that like the water that
he's that he's afraid of so we'll just
slowly get him out there what a great
playground to grow up in the Pacific
Ocean if you can get out in the
saltwater that's going to be his pool
hopefully you know if that's what he
digs all together the couple shares
three kids Levi is big bro to 13 year
old Vita and 10 year old Livingston you
got one our Elvis is very clean very
balanced our middle girl is like
um very coordinated but doesn't know
where her right hand's going or left
hand is going the other way and we've
got our Petula perpetual motion because
things fall and then there's the
youngest one who you have to wake up
very differently than the other two it
can be a long process young Livingston
out of bed and where you can greet the
day without coming out of Rage well no
rage are happening in this family moment
Camila's sharing this heartwarming snap
on the gram last week yup that's Levi
watching on as his brother gets a
haircut from Dad as mom jokes in the
caption quote then this happened right
now we have a surfer that's for sure and
it's not just Hobbies they're passing
down to their kids Matthew and Camilla
are teaching them how to use their lives
to make an impact I grew up doing it
like since I'm a little girl as long as
I can remember we always did Growing Up
and you know in Brazil it's a country
that you have a lot of poverty all
around
um so we always found ways of doing
something so I've always
you know have that on me you have a lot
of that on you as well
and showing our kids and having them
being involved on what we're doing we
are fortunate to have a very affluent
life I'm not I have having to worry if I
can pay the rent next week I'm thankful
for that there's a lot of people that do
it's very grounding for us I think it's
good it's hopefully going to be
grounding for our children too to
appreciate
every little thing one of those little
things learning how to get back on the
board I hope you dig it just keep living
huh
[Music]